I've been requested to do a video on the
cross product and it was a it's special
circumstances because I was at the point
on the physics playlist where I had to
teach magnetism anyway so this is as
good a time as any to introduce the
notion of the cross product so what's
the cross product well we've know about
vector addition vector subtraction but
what happens when you multiply vectors
and there's actually two ways to do it
with the dot product or the cross
product and just keep in mind these are
well really every operation we've
learned is defined by human beings for
some other purpose and there's nothing
different about the cross product I take
the time to say that here because the
cross product at least when I first
learned it seemed a little bit unnatural
anyway enough talk let me show you what
it is so the cross product of two
vectors let's say a vector a cross
vector B and the notation is literally
like the time sign that you knew before
you started taking algebra and using
dots and parentheses so it's literally
just an X so the cross product of
vectors a and B it's equal to and this
is going to seem very bizarre at first
but hopefully we can get a little bit of
a visual feel of what this means it
equals the magnitude of vector a times
the magnitude of vector B times the sine
of the angle between them the smallest
angle between them and now this is the
kicker and this this quantity is not
going to be just a scalar quantity it's
not just going to have magnitude it
actually has direction and that
direction we specify by the vector and
the unit vector n we could put a little
cap on it so that it's a unit vector and
the the there are a couple of things
that are special about this direction
that's specified by N 1 n is
perpendicular to both of these vectors
it is orthogonal to both of these
vectors so we'll think about a second
what that implies about it just visually
and then the other thing is the the
direction of this vector is defined by
the right-hand rule and
we'll see that in a second so so let's
let's try to think about this visually
and I have to give you an important
caveat you can only take a cross product
when we are dealing in three dimensions
a cross product really has maybe you
could define a use for it in other
dimensions or a way to take a cross
product in other dimensions but it
really only has a use in three
dimensions and that's useful because we
live in a three dimensional world
so let's see let's take some cross
product I think when you see it visually
it will make a little bit more sense
especially once you get used to the
right-hand rule so let's say that this
is let's say that's vector B I don't
have to draw straight lines but it
doesn't hurt to oh I'd have to draw it
neatly oh that was unusually I thought I
was using the line tool okay here we go
let's say that that is vector a and we
want to take the cross product of them
so this is vector a this is B I'll
probably just switch to one color
because it's hard to keep switching
between them and then the angle between
them is Theta now let's say that the
length of a is I don't know let's say
it's you know magnitude of a is equal to
five and let's say that the magnitude of
B is equal to ten it looks about double
that I'm just making up the numbers on
the fly so what's the cross product well
the magnitude part is easy let's say
this angle and let's say this angle is
equal to 30 degrees 30 degrees or if we
wanted to write it in radians
I always just because we grow up in a
world of degrees I always find it easier
to visualize degrees but we could think
about it in terms of radians as well 30
degrees is let's see there's three six
it's PI over six so we could also write
PI over 6 radians but anyway this is a
30-degree angle
so what will be a cross B a cross B is
going to equal the magnitude of a so the
length of this vector so it's going to
be equal to five times the length of
this B vector so times
ten times the sine of the angle between
them and of course there's you could
have taken the larger the obtuse angle
you could have said this was the angle
between them but I said earlier that it
was the smaller the acute angle between
them up to 90 degrees this is going to
be sine of 30 degrees times this this
vector N and we'll just it's a unit
vector so I'll go over what direction
it's actually pointing in a second let's
just figure out its magnitude so this is
equal to 50 and what's sine of 30
degrees sine of 30 degrees is 1/2 you
could type it in new calculator if
you're not sure so it's 5 times 10 times
1/2 times the unit vector I don't like
that color so that equals 25 times the
unit vector now this is where it gets
depending on your point of view either
interesting or confusing so what
direction is this unit vector pointing
into pointing in so what I said earlier
is it's perpendicular to both of these
so how can something be perpendicular to
both of these you know on it seems like
I can't draw one
well that's because right here where I
drew a and B I'm operating in two
dimensions but if I if I have a third
dimension if I could go in or out of you
know my writing pad or from from your
point of view your your screen then I
have a vector that is perpendicular to
both so imagine a vector that's I wish I
could draw it that you know is literally
going straight in at this point or
straight out at this point hopefully
you're saying let me show you the
notation for that so if I draw a vector
like this if I draw a circle with an X
in it like that that is a vector that's
going into the page or into the screen
and if I draw this that is a vector
that's popping out of the screen and
where does that convention come from
from an arrowhead because what does an
arrow look like an arrow which is our
convention for drawing vectors but an
arrow looks something like this the tip
of an arrow
it's circular and it comes to a point so
that's the tip if you look at it head-on
if it was popping out of the video and
then what does the tail of an arrow look
like it has fins right it'd be one fin
here and then to be another fin right
there and so if you took this arrow and
you were to put if you were to if you
were to go into the page and just see
the the back of the arrow or the behind
of the arrow it would look like that so
this is a vector that's going into the
page and this is a vector that's going
out of the page so we know that that n
is perpendicular to both a and B and so
the only way you can get a vector that's
perpendicular to both of these is it has
to go it essentially has to be
perpendicular or normal or orthogonal to
this plane to the plane that's your
computer screen but how do we know if
it's going in to into the screen or how
do we go know if it's coming out of the
screen this vector N and this is where
the right hand rule I know this is a
little bit overwhelming we'll do a bunch
of example problems but the right hand
rule what you do is you take your right
hand that's why it's called a right hand
rule and you take your index finger and
you point it in the direction of the
first vector in your cross-product and
order matters so let's do that so you
have to take your finger and put in the
direction of the first arrow which is a
and then you have to take your middle
finger and point it in the direction of
the second arrow B so in this case your
hand would look something like this I'm
going to try to draw it see my hand
let's see so your this is going to be so
might let me this is pushing the the
abilities of my art skills
so that's my right hand my thumb is
going to be coming down right that is my
right hand that I drew this is my index
finger and I'm pointing it in the
direction of a maybe it goes a little
bit more of this direction right then I
put my middle finger and I kind of make
an L with it or you could kind of say
like I'm it almost looks like you're
shooting a gun and I point that in the
direction of B and then whichever
direction that your thumb faces in so in
this case your thumb is going into the
page right your thumb would be going
down if you took your right hand into
this configuration so that tells us that
the vector end points into the page so
the vector end has magnitude 25 and it
points into the page so we could draw it
like that with an X if I were to attempt
to draw it in three dimensions it would
look something like this vector a let me
see if I can give some perspective so
let me see if this was straight down if
that's a vector n then a could look
something like that
let me draw in the same colors a a could
look something like that and then B
would look something like that I'm
trying to draw a three-dimensional
figure on two dimensions so it might
look a little different but I think you
get the point here I drew a and B on the
plane here I have perspective where I
was able to draw n going down but this
is how the this is this is the
definition of a cross-product now I'm
going to leave it there just because for
some reason YouTube hasn't been letting
me go over the limit as much and I will
do another video where I do several
problems and actually in the process I'm
going to explain a little bit about
magnetism and we'll take the
cross-product of several things and
hopefully you'll get a little bit better
intuition see you soon